[Musique]
à quelques jours de Noël vous faites
peut-être partie de ceux qui n'ont pas
encore choisi leur sapin parmi toutes
les variétés qu'il existe il est parfois
difficile de s'y retrouver nous sommes
donc rendus dans la jardinerie poulain à
La Queue-les-Yvelines rencontré
Sébastien Cayer qui va nous donner ses
conseils pour choisir le plus beau sapin
pour le réveillon
de toutes les couleurs ou plus
naturelles chaque année les sapins
s'arrachent en 2021 c'est 6 millions de
conifères qui ont été vendus en France
bonjour Sébastien bonjour Alors vous
travaillez ici depuis plusieurs années
aujourd'hui vous êtes responsable de
vente comment on choisit son sapin pour
Noël le sapin d'abord et avant tout faut
que ça vienne un choix du cœur on arrive
quand même vers Noël et là
malheureusement j'ai plus beaucoup de
sapin qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
mais après ça dépendra de la variété et
de ce que vous voulez en faire le sapin
de Noël idéal c'est quoi c'est un sapin
qui sent bon qui perd pas ses épines ça
dépend de finalement des goûts de chacun
ceux qui préféreront un sapin odorant
plus partir sur de l'épicéa qui
malheureusement perd ses aiguilles et
donc du coup bah on va venir le chercher
plus tardivement et ceux qui aiment un
sapin qui est beau tout le temps bah ils
vont préférer un sapin qui va garder ses
aiguilles et lui ils vont venir le
chercher dès le début décembre sans
aucun souci et du coup pour nos
spectateurs qui comme nous choisissent
leur sapin un peu tardivement comment on
conserve bien ce sapin de Noël quand on
le prend dès le début décembre l'idéal
reste de le mettre dans un dans une
soucoupe nous on vous vend des soucoupes
qui vous permettent de mettre un petit
peu d'eau et comme de la fleur coupée au
final comme une rose en vase évidemment
après il y a des petits détails on évite
de le mettre à côté de la cheminée même
si c'est très joli et très tentant ou à
côté d'un radiateur parce que forcément
il va sécher beaucoup plus vite et la
durée de vie moyenne d'un sapin c'est
combien de temps sur un Norman vous
pouvez le garder sans problème
normalement jusqu'à la galette des rois
un épicéa par contre lui bah il va
perdre beaucoup plus vite ses aiguilles
et donc forcément vous le garderez
beaucoup moins longtemps merci Sébastien
kheyer pour tous ces conseils maintenant
vous allez pouvoir choisir vos sapins et
les conserver au mieux durant toutes les
fêtes agis - 4 avant Noël certains
courageux ont affronté la pluie
l'occasion pour nous de leur demander à
quoi ressemble le sapin parfait je ne
sais pas non la forme peut-être là
effectivement quand ils achète comme ça
on peut pas avoir la forme qui leur a
par la suite ça c'est vrai non mais
faisons tous les sapins sont beaux tous
les arbres sont beaux c'est à nous de
les embellir alors épicéa ou Norman il
ne vous reste plus qu'à choisir la star
qui sortira le soir de Noël